because of the way the propaganda works
online literally anyone can be
radicalized and you don't realize
that you're being groomed into a cult
i wanted stable ground i came from a
very disorganized life
and i didn't know how to get a handle on
it i had a lot of emotional
issues around anxiety depression and
adhd
and i wasn't getting treatment for any
of these things and the answers
of everyone around me seemed so
complicated and unattainable but the
answers
that i got from the content creators
that i listened to
they had just such a clear and directed
focus and path of how to solve it
and that path became increasingly more
dark as i went through
ideas about male supremacy racial
supremacy
the dangers of muslim immigration or the
dangers
of liberalism i was being told that in
order to get those things
all the things that i wanted in life the
stability the happiness that solid
ground
that this was the pathway to doing that
and you don't realize
that you're being groomed into a cult it
was like i was in this whole other world
it was like a soap opera there's this
huge
epic drama and that's what i was
watching i was watching a movie on a
screen
the alt-right and things like q and on
and a lot of these
i'd put them on the dangerous side of
the cult of the cult spectrum
i am 100 behind cue he's working for the
president he's working for our country
they are totalist in their control they
demand total
obedience uh to the ideology they are
very very hostile to the
you know any sort of out group there's a
sort of walling off of information that
happens
in my life i basically became very
abrasive and argumentative
and increasingly more angry and negative
these were all things that were already
aspects of me
but that propaganda in that world was
amplifying all the worst parts of me
i think anybody is capable of the worst
kind of violence and when i saw christ
church happened
it made me feel a sense of urgency
because i thought well this isn't just
some internet thing this is
this is going to keep happening it is
clear that this can now only be
described
as a terrorist attack that event right
there
it is the logical conclusion of a belief
system
as as heinous as white nationalism
when i left i came across counter
content in the form of
the twitch streamer destiny
i ironically love this channel who
disengaged me
in a way by attacking the figureheads
that i had watched and discrediting them
on their terms
embarrassing them in public youtube
debates i am like a democrat or
progressive you'd call me a leftist in
the united states but for people online
that talk about like socialism and
marxism
i would not be considered a leftist i'd
be considered a liberal and then also i
was going into discord communities
and meeting people all over the world
and this
very narrow world view that i've been
given i realized that
it was a lot more complicated and then i
had a lot more allies in places i didn't
expect
when i look at something like january
6th
[Applause]
i was there that day and taking pictures
and the thing i was looking at was the
different groups you know you have your
people
which are your desperate ones they're
being inspired by the messages of hope
coming from trump
and from these movements you have your
truth seekers who feel that the world's
you know slighted them or screwed them
over in many ways it has
and you know so these turn into your
conspiracy theories and so
there really is not one reason that
everybody's joining this
but to me what's more terrifying is this
sort of broader tent that this
ideology is creating this this sort of
you know fake populist directionless
movement which riles people up and turns
them against their governments
and makes it basically to where
democracy can't function
it is it's almost like your country is
full of sleeper cells
that's really really really terrifying
the way that we push back on this threat
is first get people the material needs
that they need in their life
food shelter health care get people
things in their life to give them
purpose that could be a church it could
be a community
and in terms of the internet people got
to be more mindful when they're on
social media
there needs to be more regulations on
social media what we really need though
is we need a new way to have this
conversation about far-right cults
about supremacist cults about white
nationalism
approaching it from this very offensive
um direct trying to cancel people or
push people out of society it's not
going to work anymore because
it's not just young white men getting
radicalized into this
it's not just people out in the country
it's not just republicans it's not just
the uneducated
it's literally everyone the truth is
much more nuanced and difficult
and uncomfortable than the simple
answers of extremists
you